hey guys I'm just it is the 10th of
November today and here's the important
things that have happened in gaming the
Xbox one holiday update is out now and
here's what you're getting with it
the new update is introducing features
including clubs that looking for group
and group messaging as well as a new
achievement rarity notification system
all these features have been available
to people in the Xbox preview program
for some time but it's now rolling out
publicly across Xbox one and PC the
update also makes changes to the gamers
core leader board which will reset at
the start of every month and you've now
got emoji as part of the Xbox one
virtual keyboard for when nothing but a
cat with heart eyes can properly display
your emotions
Microsoft has opted to keep the arena
feature in testing for a while longer
however arena allows people to create
tournaments and challenges directly on
Xbox Live so Detroit red have responded
to rumors that they're under threat from
a hostile takeover earlier this week so
Witcher 3 developer announced on
November 29 meeting with shareholders to
vote on measures that would help defend
in the case of a potential hostile
takeover said approached red have since
clarified this is only to vote on
preventative measures should the company
ever find itself under threat and isn't
in response to any recent event late
last year there were reports that EA was
attempting to buyouts at a proactive but
these were later denied by the developer
finally digital foundry has discovered
that the ps4 pro version of Skyrim
special edition has some framerate
issues the report revealed that while
the game does benefit from the native 4k
resolution the framerate has taken a bit
of a hit as a result of the increased
vision of fidelity and I really do mean
a bit digital foundry explained in
like-for-like situations the ps4 pro
game sees a 2 to 3 FPS deficit resulting
in more noticeable stutter compared to
the title running on the standard ps4
console the base ps4 performance isn't
impacted to the same degree with only a
few 1 to 3 FPS drops copping up on
occasion across a general run of play
the report adds that while shadow
quality in general effects remain very
similar foliage draw distance and the
resolution are improved that is
everything I have
today head to GameSpot for stories on
Rainbow six siege and The Last Guardian
and do remember that extra life is
beginning on GameSpot tomorrow at noon
I'll see you again tomorrow for the top
stories of the week